the jurogan experience well there's a
you know there's a suspicion like people
have suspicion about the government like
there's a lot of people that don't want
to get the vaccine because they're
worried about the government
that that's also that that exists in
minority communities and in
in more poor communities what are your
thoughts about this vaccine
passport concept because a lot of people
find that
deeply problematic giving the government
this ability to let people
travel or not travel based on whether or
not you've been vaccinated
the left cannot let go of covet they
can't let go of it they want it around
they want to keep spending money
based on on this sort of moral stance
that we need to keep
supporting communities because of covid
and that we need to keep doing things
and taking excessive action
because of kovit they not let it go
because they love collectivism and they
love
centralized control of the economy and
society
well i i recall a definition we were
looking at earlier
but and again i always distinguish
between liberals and progressives
on this one okay i think i think there
is a there should be an alliance between
real liberals and conservatives in the
future and that's how we're going to
solve problems
you know i talked to brett weinstein all
the time you know weinstein if you talk
to miles time you know his [ __ ] last
name
jesus harvey weinstein
brett weinstein all right anyway i think
anyway he's like i'm a hardcore liberal
he's like i'm a radical liberal and and
we just agree on so many things
because he's a classical liberal and if
you're going to describe yourself as
liberal
you mean the classical sense in most
cases and you want nice things you have
the sense of compassion
and you want nice things for people
maybe it's health care maybe it's to
take care of people when they fall in on
hard times these are good things these
are not bad things
they're not things that conservatives
even disagree with we now we generally
have a different philosophy on how to
how to find solutions for those problems
that's the so that's the
center i get if we're always like
grasping for the center
which a lot of people are and you know i
always kind of question like what do you
mean by that
but maybe that's the right way to look
at it liberals are good
at having enough empathy and compassion
to see
what might need to be changed
conservatives are good at finding the
solutions
for that change that maintains the good
things that got us here in the first
place you can't burn down all the
foundations of a society
just because you're not at utopia yet
remember utopia is defined as
in greek as being nowhere and you'll
always you'll always burn things down to
grasp for that
you can't get to that point so i think
that's the right alliance
um kind of i kind of forgot
what the initial question was though
well it's it's all
you're talking about the difference
between uh a classical
liberal well when you say classical
liberal i always think you're trying to
like pretend you're
you're liberal when you're really a
conservative like because there's a lot
of people that use that term classical
liberal
and it's like what do you believe like
it's like things get sneaky
i think there's a real problem with
definitions there's a real problem with
like
you got to focus on the definition what
chris rock was saying though about like
gangs like that you you have like i'm
more conservative and i believe you have
these predetermined patterns of behavior
that people subscribe to
without any independent thinking without
any objective thinking
and it's a real problem with human
beings like i think ultimately what
everybody wants
is what's good for the community the
everybody what they want for themselves
selfishly
but they also want for their friends and
neighbors and loved ones and family
members
they want what's good for everybody but
they can't agree in what is good for
everybody
and then when people don't have they
look at people who do have
and they go well how the [ __ ] do they
have and then some grifter will come
along and they have because they've
taken from you
and that that therein lies the problem
because if you're not
educated or if you haven't like deeply
researched the ideas
especially with an objective perspective
you can sort of believe a lot of these
grifters a lot of these people that come
along and they
they say crazy [ __ ] like tax the rich
or eat the rich and like oh jesus christ
had
how did they get rich did they did they
get rich from
stealing or did they get rich from
discipline and hard work
and decades decades in the trenches
dealing with two very different things
well classically liberal
philosophy would ask that question
because because there's a
because there's a sense of justice
involved with any question
and and that sense of justice is did
somebody infringe on your rights
and what are rights life liberty
property generally speaking
in the classical sense now you can go
you can go further back in time before
classic enlightenment principles came
about in the
you know 18th century um but then you're
but then you're dealing with feudalism
then you're dealing with tribalism then
you're dealing with what
i think a lot on the left want to bring
us back to the sort of subjugating
people
into different identities and
hierarchies based on those identities
that's a really bad place to be they
want to bring us back to that moment in
history
what the enlightenment period did was
say look you can keep dividing people up
all day long
eventually you just get to an individual
so maybe we should look at how
individuals act and then have a
have a really rational structure about
how we how we define incentives
and how we define justice and justice
should be defined as
as somebody infringing a person a
infringing on the rights of person b
yeah or or person a you know making it
um in a hierarchy for for unworthy
reasons something other than a
meritocracy that would be an injustice
now i know you said that the the left is
fascinated by covid or obsessed with
covid but
we didn't really cover it like sorry
that was the original question
i got really philosophical no it's okay
that that that was the original question
well it's obviously a bad idea it's not
and it's obviously a bad idea because
like the and a lot of the
well-intentioned people on the left tend
to
they're well-intentioned but they do
tend to live like they're still in grad
school and i know because
i went to harvard in a in school i went
to the harvard kennedy school after the
military
and there's an infatuation with being
able to design the perfect policy on
paper
now that's the first step of course now
the second step is how do you implement
it
and also again whose rights are you
infringing on when you implement these
things these are the questions they
don't ask
this is what a conservative always asks
again when i talk about
how to solve problems through a
framework of limiting principles this is
what i mean
you have to ask these questions and so
what how
you know what is the practicality of
this and it's it's not practical at all
frankly depending on what they mean by a
coveted passport
also maybe we should define that first
um but
but it's one thing to ask people like
hey i don't know wear a green bracelet
if uh if you already got the vaccine and
you've already had covet or both
either or but it's not that it's like
limiting your ability to travel
which is an excessive infringement on
your rights
and also and also is it really even
scientific
given the trends that we're seeing i
mean in all
no matter how you approach this question
it seems like a really bad idea
when you say is it even scientific what
do you mean by that
meaning we've been traveling for a year
without vaccines
some well in a limited aspect some
people have
traveled a lot limited capacity yeah i
mean it's
somewhat limited some well no if you
look at the airline
trends yeah severely limited fairly yeah
i i've spent a lot of time at airports
well you do but that's a that's but i
know but i know i know how crowded they
are
every time i'm there and yeah there was
definitely a time period where there
were ghost towns
but that hasn't been the case for many
many but it's still not even 50 percent
of what it was a year ago yeah or a year
and a half ago
i don't know the exact numbers i don't
know what it is i just know that we've
been living
with it just like you have to live with
a pandemic because you don't have a
choice
there's a big difference maybe maybe
everything boils down to this difference
the wright believes look you don't have
a choice you got to make the best of it
you got to keep living you got to
you got to mitigate risk where you can
but you can't mitigate risk at the
expense of
everything else and the left says no no
no
you have to mitigate risk at the expense
of everything else no cost is too high
because if it just saves one life
this is the fundamental difference the
problem they don't take into account is
it costs a lot of lives it costs a lot
of lives through
suicide depression drug addiction
there's a lot of
schools closing has been excessively bad
and there's no science to indicate that
this is that this is what our
kids need i have a friend who lives in
nevada and their community
was ravaged by suicide with uh young
kids
and they're devastated by and they're
trying to figure out like what there's a
massive escalation of suicides in high
school aged kids because of
the pandemic on the lockdown you have a
higher chance of dying from the flu if
you're under 20 years old why doesn't dr
fauci ever say that
why does it why does he go hey you could
die if you're 14. you could yes you
could but you have to contextualize the
information you're giving this is why
america has lost trust in their public
health officials because they never
contextualize anything they never give
you the probability of risk
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience